in Fire Emblem fates you have a lot of
decisions to make which is why we're
here with a crash course in tactics I'm
Chris waters from GameSpot and I'm ash
Paulson from GameXplain welcome to the
second episode of inside Fire Emblem
fates a series sponsored by Nintendo in
which we help you be the best amnesiac /
chosen one / dragon person / commander
you can be so let's hit the ground
running you'll battle in a lot of
different places throughout the
campaigns of birthright and conquest but
the importance of knowing where your
enemies are is always paramount tap X
for a quick look at all the spaces where
your enemies can strike and then use
that to plan your movements I like to
take a strong defender and put them just
within the enemies range to lure them
into attacking most enemies won't engage
you until you enter their range so if
you're careful you can avoid alerting
more enemies until you've finished off
the ones you're dealing with also you
can select an individual enemy to see
their specific movement range
highlighted in red which is especially
helpful when you have flying unit - the
enemy has archers yeah
picture your Pegasus and wyvern riders
like a pile of gas soaked rags and enemy
archers are the match always be aware of
the battlefield terrain and use the info
in the top-left corner as a guide groves
of trees can confer a defensive boost
while desert sands can slow unit
movement to a crawl and check your unit
skills to see who does better in what
terrain cavaliers like silas can hit
harder when they have open fields to run
it knowing your army skills can nudge
you toward victory and though enemy
units will have their own skills as well
you don't have to worry about them in
the early going now that's a birthright
talk right there oh is it
yeah man in conquest the enemy skills
cause problems straight out of the gate
I'm talking poison damage lunge attacks
stuff that will shake you up if you're
not on guard at all times like a bomb
there you go again with your conquest
boasting we get it it's challenging it
doesn't make you cool oh and I suppose
hanging out with your birth family and
birthright does your words not mine oh
you are just insufferable Oh
typical norian dramatics okay
even though birthright doesn't start off
too tough you should always be
positioning your units next to each
other this lets them double down when
attacking and boost their chances to
avoid damage while defending when facing
the hefty or challenge of conquest you
should consider not just supporting
allies but pairing them so they occupy
the same tile the main fighter gains a
stat boost while the support fighter is
protected from all attacks you can
trigger dual guard this way which
completely negates an attack and you'll
be protected against extra attacks from
any friends the enemies might have
fighting next to them because hey guess
what your enemies they can team up to
you bet your sweet bippy they can and
really who can blame them not only this
fighting together enable all those
powerful offensive and defensive
strategies it also brings your soldiers
closer together as friends ah isn't that
sweet I mean yeah it kinda is
conversations and relationships that you
can unlock are definitely part of the
fun of Fire Emblem and if friends become
more than friends then you can count on
some new recruits to join the squad
baby time now let's talk leveling it's
super important soldiers gain experience
for doing damage so you want to get them
in on as many fights as possible if you
have a dude who's lined up to kill an
enemy in one hit let a weaker Ally take
a potshot at that enemy before you pop
them off every little bit helps and
that's a strategy with your healers and
your singer as well you should heal or
sing on every turn even if it doesn't
seem tactically necessary because
leveling up is always tactically
necessary these tips go for conquest as
well but while birthright has a bunch of
extra challenge battles to help bolster
your leveling conquest offers less of
these opportunities so you have to make
the most of each battle now let's take
mozu for example mozu I know her pair
log1 everyone she knows murdered by
faceless monsters right before her eyes
yep oh yeah mozu she's not very good no
she is not but she gets good the best
way to level weaker fighters is to have
your other soldiers whittle down an
enemy's health and then have the
weakling make the kill shot pretty soon
that weakling will be one tough cookie
but the most formidable fighters don't
just level up and they class up using a
master seal once you've reached level 10
you can evolve your soldier into an
awesome reversion of the
selves giving them big stat bonuses and
possibly enabling new weapons and skills
you don't want to rush into it though
keep going until you hit level 20 and
you'll have milked your basic class for
all the stat boosts it's worth then
master seal it up and become more
powerful than you ever imagined oh my
god so many tips so many strategies okay
let's pick up the pace by hand axes and
javelins for your axe and sphere users
so they can have a ranged attack option
dragon vanes can do some cool stuff and
don't forget that any royal character
can use them your friends your enemies
anyone with that weirdo royal blood keep
an eye out for glittering spots in the
battlefield to pick up some bonus items
or boost your weapon proficiency use the
store all and optimize commands in the
unit selection screen before each battle
to make sure that those cool weapons
you've been acquiring end up in the
right hands without you having to fiddle
around too much Terran ninja with a
flying unit to have them soar over
barriers and unlock hard-to-reach chests
save those permanent stat boosting items
for the characters you really care about
on and off the battlefield or just give
them for yourself after every fight
attend to any and all exclamation points
on your castle map or in your support
conversation then save your progress
never pet a burning dog be sure to wait
what oh sorry wrong game okay well there
are many deeper strategies to discover
within Fire Emblem fates conquest and
birth right but these should get you
well on your way it's a lot to take in
but stick with it and come on back to
share some of your own tips in the
comments below I'm ash Paulson and I'm
Chris waters saying thanks for watching
inside Fire Emblem fates and long live
the kingdom of hoshido
you